all of us have had to get used to at
least some empty shells in the shops
so is that christmas dinner
safe let's ask ian wright chief
executive of the food and drink
federation
mr right
the wine and spirits association in a
letter signed by
for nine firms wrote to the transport
secretary this week uh warning that
delivery chaos
could impact people's christmas
how likely do you think that that is
well good morning trevor i think the
crucial word there is could
uh there are all sorts of variables as
we approach the last few weeks running
up to christmas and one of them has just
been introduced in the last 24 hours and
it's the one that you've been talking
about for most of the morning i i think
the the new variant and what impact that
will have on the supply chain but i
think at the moment what we're seeing is
a series of shortages driven by later on
shelf and on
menus in clubs and restaurants around
the country many of your viewers will
have noticed the disappearance of
specials boards on restaurant menus
and i think all of those shortages are
caused by real tightness in the labor
market and by some international factors
to do with the global supply chains
all of those are being worked round as
the
chief executive of little told us this
week it's increasingly hard to work
around all the problems but many of them
can be solved and i think at the moment
you could look forward to your christmas
goose rather exotic if i may say so
with some with some appreciation and
some hope
well i i i'm i am absolutely reassured
about that thank you very much i think
is that exotic but um maybe i'm maybe
i'm a bit too european these days uh
what about um the the veg spuds and
particularly the wine and and brandy for
uh
pudding
well i think i think the wine and
spirits trade trade association the
experts in this area are making an
important point which is that some
particular sectors have difficulties
that others are not enjoying so i think
most of your vegetables will be
relatively safe and of course in the
next few weeks we will undoubtedly hear
about individual areas of shortage the
the issue here is that these shortages
can be random they can be very quick to
occur they may often not be about supply
itself but they may be about the ability
to move the product and and the key
thing for us
is that we've got this really serious
difficulty in the labor market which
means that for some people it's almost
impossible to bring in staff to manage
their manage their christmas bulge as it
were so i know of one firm which i was
talking to on friday where they're 40
workers short on a working population of
120 that means their shifts are really
really tight they can't get everybody uh
they need to do the work and as a
consequence they're leaving losing half
a million pounds a month in orders now
at a time of high of increasingly high
inflation and a lot of uncertainty in
the supply chain that's a worry and i
think one of the concerns i would have
trevor is not just about christmas but
about some of the problems that are
being stored up for the weeks after
christmas in terms of high inflation in
wage costs and in terms of the viability
of some businesses depending on their
ability to trade through christmas
you're quite right to um take me to task
for wanging on about christmas because
actually uh the real question here is is
this a temporary or according to the
bank of england a transitory
event or do you think that we have now
started to build in
higher labor cost and higher inflation
for the foreseeable future
yes i do and i also think that this
disruption is permanent so long as there
is as long as we have a situation where
there aren't enough people to do the
jobs we have and incidentally we did a a
piece of work about eight weeks ago
which showed us that of the four million
jobs in the food supply chain from farm
to fork
about half a million of them are not
filled so that's one in eight of the
jobs in food and drink from the farm
right way through manufacturing retail
and hospitality are not filled and
that's about half the vacancies in the
uk workforce now as long as those people
aren't there there will be impacts one
of those impacts will be disruption in
supply
and it depends where in the supply chain
people can't get
can't get labor to do the work that's
necessary and one of those impacts will
be wage inflation as people compete
for uh the workforce that is available
and that will have the long-term impact
on inflation in the uk economy and there
are other pressures there too there are
very significant commodity price
increases we all know about the gas
price and other fuel price increases so
that world food inflation at the moment
according to
two unl organizations is running at 20
per year there was a study in
agriculture in the uk last week that
showed that agricultural imp inflation
was over 30
now these are scary figures they won't
all feed through to the retail prices
index because there are lots of other
mitigations but they are a concern and
they are for the long term as is this
disruption
ian wright thank you very much indeed